and a plea for help tonight after a
woman's dog was stolen from her
southwest valley home while police work
to track down those responsible she
hopes maybe the community will be on the
lookout for her beloved pet madison
kimbrough is live from metro
headquarters with her story tonight
madison
valerie ramirez filed a police report
with metro but thanks to her neighbor
police now have more information to go
off of regarding these possible suspects
i received a notification from my
security system that was going off and i
see that someone is breaking into my
home valerie ramirez asking for the
public's help after her home was broken
into tuesday morning and her dog was
stolen
all of this caught on camera around 8
a.m archie who was just an
eight-month-old pekingese toy poodle mix
was heard barking when the intruder
carried him away a neighbor recalls
seeing the whole ordeal and thinking
something was off looked over here i
heard her alarm
dog was obviously yelping a guy came
running out with a hoodie just like
holding it like super weird the dog was
obviously kind of in like discomfort so
it was definitely weird seeing something
like that luckily that neighbor was able
to obtain the license plate number of
the suspect when he drove off and gave
that information to police but
unfortunately thinks the intruder wasn't
acting alone someone was posted up in
front of her house and as soon as like
she pulled away like he gave a signal to
his friend and then like zoomed off it
was obviously a two-person team i think
they wanted to make sure that i was
out of the neighborhood and not you know
turning around or anything as for
valuables nothing else in ramirez's home
was taken just archie so for that reason
she believes she was a target and that
this wasn't a random act
and take a look at this flyer valerie is
offering a reward for anyone with
information pertaining to archie's
whereabouts he is microchipped and the
hope is that he is found safely brought
home and metro police can be contacted
with any information reporting live at
metro headquarters madison kimbrough
live local now madison thank you for
that